sie scheint wohl über derzeit zu stehen
diese musik vor mehr als 300 jahren hat
sie bach komponiert und sie bewegt uns
singt und klingt in uns bis heute
manche seiner werke sind wahre klassik
hits wie die goldberg variationen
und auch die so selten gesungenen
kantaten die rudolf lutz hier im
appenzellischen drogen einspielt
erreichen eine weltweite facebook
fangemeinde
selbst unser handy trällert bach
nein das finde ich lustig aber wenn du
gard an fuge ablauf verlor die idee hier
den lachen
wie sollen wir uns denn über komponisten
vorstellen
sicher er war thomaskantor in leipzig
inspiriert bis heute die bewohner seiner
stadt wie den comic zeichner andré
martin bach hat den berühmten
thomanerchor geleitet
und an ihm gelitten
cholerisch beschreiben internet schüler
und dennoch beseelt seine musik die
sänger bis heute ideal
januar
rudolf lutz wird bach auch nicht so
schnell los
plant doch die bach stiftung über einen
zeitraum von 25 jahren alle vokalwerke
aufzuführen
jeden monat eine kantate
ein unternehmen fast so gewaltig wie der
große musiker selbst und es kommt
zeitgemäß daher alle einspielungen
werden aufwändig gefilmt und über
youtube und itunes von drogen in die
welt geschickt bach im digitalen
zeitalter
das theater chur hat die kantate o
ewigkeit du donner wort als szenisches
bach theater auf die bühne gebracht
peter konwitschny und johannes harneit
inszenieren sie als wissenschaftlichen
kongress über das phänomen zeit auf dem
selbst albert einstein an der frage nach
der ewigkeit verzweifelt ewigkeit du
machst mir bange
ich glaube es geht mir um das was
möglicherweise nach dem tod kommt
ich meine dass der tod nicht schön ist
es weiß doch jeder
das macht mich nicht reifer das reifer
macht mich der andere schmerz nämlich
dass ich einfach mal weg bin
das kann ich mir eigentlich nicht
vorstellen ich kann das nicht fassen
bachs kantaten behandeln also ganz
existenzielle fragen die auch
nichtgläubige etwas angehen was ist
ewigkeit wo bin ich wenn ich tot bin und
er kleidet diese fragen in einer ebenso
allgemeingültige musik
in chur ist johannes harneit der herr
über die allgemeingültige musik bei bach
bedarf es keiner überzeugungsarbeit
nicht alle musiker glauben an gott aber
alle glauben an wach das habe ich auch
hier in der einführung in chur gesagt
damit ist eigentlich glaube ich viel
erzählt kein musiker kann ernsthaft
versuchen einfach vorbeizukommen
und so endet die inszenierung in chur
zwar in irdischen streit
doch mit fast schon himmlische musik